our next topic is the false Discovery
rate this is similar to the familywise
error rate this is a a sort of quantity
that you know statisticians have worked
out how to design testing procedures so
that we have a guarantee that we can
control this quantity um at a reasonable
level and so the big difference between
the false Discovery rate and the
familywise error rate is the false
Discovery rate is really not as strict
the family-wise error rate what it tries
to control is a pro chance of making any
mistakes and the fal Discovery rate
roughly speaking tries to control the
proportion of mistakes among the
rejected that are that are that we make
so if we make if we reject 100 um
hypothesis uh you know we can expect if
we control the F Discovery rate around
20% that about 20 of those 100 are
likely to be truly null that that we
didn't actually make a discovery but on
the other hand we would have made maybe
80 out of 100 True discoveries in many
in many situations this is much more
useful you think of a biologist who's
looking to find genes that are
responsible for a type of cancer um if
you declare there's 25 genes responsible
based on testing and you say the false
Discovery rate is is is 5% then you know
you have a good you have some idea of of
those 25 genes that you've discovered
how many are likely to be false
discoveries but the bulk of them will be
good discoveries that's more that's a
more meaningful um way of controlling
the error rate when you do multiple
testing yes yeah so there are some some
places where fiz error might be like in
a clinical trial for instance if you
don't want to have any really adverse
reactions that might be better rather
than having some proportion of adverse
reactions you might want to have very
few so there their their applications
vary but false Discovery rate is
certainly a very very popular and
meaningful in many contexts so we're
we're instead of genes like Trevor's
example here we're going to we're going
to apply the false discovery rate to to
our fund manager so we have 2,000 fund
managers earlier we looked at five of
them and we're going to try and uh
choose a a threshold for the P values
that um to control the the the um the
false Discovery rate and the big
difference in terms of implementation
we're going to use the same function to
compute adjusted P values it's using
instead of home and Bon foroni we give
this FDR B8 as the argument so FDR
stands for false Discovery rate BH is
stands for Benjamin hawber which is the
the procedure that's used to control the
fiz discovery
rate okay and uh so when we look at the
these things are called um often called
Q values rather than P values uh so when
we look at now the first 10 uh Q values
we actually see a really strong
performing manager actually no longer is
under 5% on the other hand um well it's
not necessarily clear that 5% is the
right threshold often for FDR people
will choose a threshold like 20% instead
of instead of 5% so at a 20% FDR cut off
manager the first manager looks pretty
well so maybe you will still want his
phone number later
Chev okay
um so let's take a look comparing these
two methods so suppose we control false
Discovery at 10% how many of our
managers are you know out of the 2000
seem to be beating uh the the market at
a level of 10% well it seems um there
are 146 of them that beat the market
that according to this threshold of 10%
are beating the market so we'd expect
out of these 150 you know roughly 15 or
so would be um you know might be ones
who can't really beat the market um and
are may be guessing randomly or
something like that let's compare that
to Bon Ferron
so the the simple way to implement the
bonferoni procedure is just to take the
raw P values and um we either multiply
them and compare it to 10% or take the
10% and divide it by the number of P
values so 01 divided by 2,000 and we see
here actually no one seems to be
outperforming the market um uh that way
so if these were genes and there were
actually some really important genes
well we would have made more discoveries
um for potenti future research if we
controled F false Discovery rate then
family wise error
rate so there's a plot that goes along
with the Benjamin Haw procedure that
that's quite popular and we're just
going to take a a look at it below so
there's a there's a a particular rule um
for uh Benjamin hawber and I'll just
write it quickly here it compares the
the J smallest P value that's pcore J to
um the quantity uh Alpha let that's say
10% .1 * J / M so it Compares these two
things P you know it asks whether the JP
value is smaller than that threshold or
not and that L that's what this line
here uh represents and the way the uh
the procedure is done is uh it finds the
um let's see the the largest J that is
the most liberal threshold the last time
that PJ is less than or equal to Alpha J
over M and that's you can see here these
are the P values and this is the last
time this curve is below this dash line
so this marks the Benjamin hawber
threshold and it rejects everything to
the left and you see it actually
included some of these P values that to
start off didn't seem to get under that
line um so if we if we stopped the first
time the P value was not less than that
we would have stopped here and that
would be you know that would be nothing
um so this is a sort of visual
description of the benjamini hawber
procedure